Andre Floria two questions question 12a
the mechanism for creating chorus is not
yet fully understood what would be the
most likely explanation for their
formation well it's pretty complicated
but it's quite clear that carbon is one
of the fastest nucleating company atoms
or elements that we have if you if you
make it it zips up to thousands very
quickly from a hot plasma and carbon
molecules and Graphite's visa don't
actually melt no one seemed liquid
graphite to my knowledge or liquid
diamond but I think what happens is that
from carbonate and plasma that we
produce with a laser and we vaporize
graphite carbon chains first form
I think carbon and linear Kuhlman linear
ish carbon C 1 C 2 C 3 C 4 C 5 C 6 and
so on and my colleague David Walton
really had a brilliant way of making
long carbon chain molecules with just
things on the end so it was quite clear
you could make a carbon chain up to 30
carbon atoms my guess is what is
happening in the range when they get up
to the 18 19 20 other things are forming
and we think that there are also mono
cyclic ring Zin which the chain turns
into a bead chain you know a ring of
carbon atoms and a non-cycling ring I
think that's now been proven by some
really neat science by John Myers group
in Basel and it was conjectured many
years ago by theoreticians and then
around 20 to 30 to 40 to 50 I think
these coalesce and into cages and these
cages may we're pretty sure we've got
some results here student Paul done
working with myself and Alan Marshall
to the mad lab we're shown that there
are definitely species with 28 carbon
atoms which are cages there's the
circumstantial but nevertheless pretty
definitely cage structures so at that
point have you've got these little
balloons if you wish I think what
happens then is carbon atoms and carbon
molecules coalesce into this and are
sort of ingested into this network
through a neck network in to see for
4050 and so on and when they hit c60
they hit the first stable structure the
see 60s the first state will full ring
and then that point is a cul-de-sac and
so a lot get locked into that some go
shooting on 270 and others too high ones
and we get something like carbon plasma
as you get the issue and you extract
them ten percent of the cert which large
particles are in the form of fluorines
and sort of like minus 80 to 90 percent
of c 60 about 10 percent c 70 and a few
percent and now all the others with more
and more carbon atoms then of course now
achieves and many other things so
basically i think that you have this
cage forming for other smaller levels
and then others being ingested into this
structure and they stop when they get to
see 60 and that's why 660 is strong so
hand waving and i think that's about as
far as i'm prepared to go it's just very
very complicated and people have been
looking at combustion process for 50
years and fearing theorizing and doing
experiments and they miss C 60 so I'll
sure they got it right but I don't know
it's it's very complicated and I think
the best theory is my rule of theory
where it all comes together best I can
do